hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
climbing stairs so this is going to be
another dynamic programming problem
and this is definitely more on the easy
side definitely compared to some of the
really hard
dynamic programming problems that we've
been solving recently but i still think
that this is a good problem to really
understand the fundamentals understand
you know the brute force
and taking that brute force you know
using memoization and then of course
getting the true dynamic programming
solution
and by the way if you don't already know
we have been tracking a list of blind 75
questions on the spreadsheet so today
we're going to be solving this dynamic
programming one
the climbing stairs problem so i will be
adding the solution once this video is
uploaded
and the link will be in the description
if you do want to take a look at this
sheet
so the problem statement is pretty
simple we're climbing a staircase and
it's going to take us
n steps to reach the top of the
staircase
every time we take a step we have two
choices of how we can take a step
we can either just take one single step
or we can take
two steps at once and all we want to
know is
how many different ways can we get to
the top of the staircase
so let's look at the first example n
equals two that means we need to climb
two steps so we could draw the picture
kind of like this right so
let's say we start over here right this
is step
zero basically when we haven't climbed
anything and our goal is to get up here
which clearly is
two steps right so starting from here we
know we can make two choices right we
can take
one step and that would land us over
here or we could take
two steps and that would land us over
here so already we're seeing
one way is to just take two steps right
that's what this path
would take us right that's one way we
could reach the goal right just taking
two steps at once
now if we ended up taking one step then
we would be
at this position so from here we would
we would have that same exact choice
right we can take
one step or we can take two steps now
clearly if we take two steps we've gone
too far right we were
only trying to climb two steps total but
if we you know end up over here
then you know that's not going to count
as a path right so that would not count
but as you can see if we took one step
initially then we could take another
single step and that would be another
way so either
this is one way we could reach two steps
or we could just take
a single double step right so clearly
there are two different ways we could
climb the staircase and that's also the
result
of this problem and they basically
explain it over here
so let's look at the second example
which is basically if we're climbing
three steps instead of two right so
let's look at the drawing so once again
we're gonna do the exact same thing that
we did right from here we could take
one step or we could take two steps
right
and so so far we'd get here but remember
our goal is to climb three steps so
let's continue
so from here we could take one step
which would land us at the result or we
could take
two steps which would get us out of
bounds right that's not what we want to
do
so so far we have found one way to get
us to the result
but let's continue that from over here
again we can take a single step which
would get us over here or we can take
two steps which would get us at the
result so now we've found two different
ways we can get to the last step
and lastly we still have a path to
continue right we got here
by taking one step and then taking
another single step so
here we have two choices take one step
get to the result or take two steps and
get out of bounds
so in the end we see that there were
three different ways
we were able to get to this last step as
you can see this is getting really hard
to visualize
with a single staircase a more easy way
would be
to get a decision tree to visualize and
at
every decision remember we can take one
step or we can take two steps so let's
try to visualize the problem like that
and see if we can notice any patterns
so let's say we're given n equals five
we're trying to climb
five steps so we can consider just like
the previous drawing that we're starting
at step
zero and our goal is to get to step five
now remember
at every given point we have two
decisions to make
we can climb one step or we can climb
two steps right and depending on the
decision that we make
each of these is going to lead to a
different path we can take to get to the
result and remember
all we're trying to do is count the
number of ways we can get to that result
so in this decision tree you know we're
gonna keep making two decisions at every
step and at the end
we're gonna count how many different
ways were we
able to get to five steps reached
so we can get to step one and we can get
to step two let's just continue drawing
out the decision tree from here we can
make two more decisions
we can take one step which would get us
to two we can take two steps get us to
three
and similar here we can take one step
get us to three
two steps get us to four from here we
can also take one step
get us to three two steps get us to four
one step get us to four two steps get us
to five
now here we can see that we reached the
result right n equals five
so this is our first path that we
could reach to get us to the result
right you can see we took
one step then we took two steps then we
took another two steps so this is our
result
once we get to it that's our base case
right we're gonna solve this recursively
right that's pretty much what we're
doing this decision tree is basically
recursion
and this is our base case we wouldn't
want to continue
if we got here so here we would return
one we found one way to get to the
result but for the remaining paths let's
continue so here we can take one step or
two
that'd get us to four this would get us
to five so you can see once again we
found
another way we can get to the results so
so far we have two different paths that
can lead us to step five
and here let's do the same thing if we
take one step we get to five that's the
result if we take two steps we get to
six
that means we overshot right we went too
far this is another base case
if this number of steps ever exceeds
five then we're going to return
zero right we found zero ways from this
path that can reach
the result so now let's continue over
here again we take one step or two
so we'll get to four or five another
path that leads us to the result
and here we can also take one step or
two which would get us five
or six similarly over here right this is
another
four so the exact same thing is going to
happen do you start to see
we're repeating the exact same problem
multiple times how can we better solve
this problem knowing that
so now we have another four we're just
going to repeat the exact same thing
that we just did before right take one
step or two we know we're gonna get to a
five and we know we're going to get to a
six
so you can see every path led to the
base case except for this last one so
let's complete this we can take one
step which would get five or two steps
six okay so now our entire decision tree
is complete so what's the result gonna
be remember red means we're gonna return
zero green means we're gonna return one
so let's just count the number of greens
one two three four five six seven eight
so there were eight different paths from
the beginning that could reach step five
but remember since we started here we
were asking how many different ways
starting at zero can we get to five and
then we got to a
sub problem we got to a sub problem of
starting at step
one how many ways can we reach five from
this decision tree alone we see that
there's one
two three four five different ways we
can reach the result
and down two if we're starting at step
two
there's three different ways we can
reach the result now if you solve the
problem like this
basically using recursion and you could
probably do it with depth first search
because this is basically a tree and
what would be the time complexity of
that well clearly we you can see that we
have two decisions each time so it's
going to be 2 to the power of the height
of this tree what's the height going to
be
it's going to be roughly n equals 5
right you can see that this is going to
be the longest path so that's roughly
the height so the overall time
complexity is going to be 2 to the power
of
n that's not super efficient but you can
see here
we're repeating the same problem
multiple times right when we get over
here we're
asking how many different ways starting
from 2 can we get to five right
and down in this decision tree we found
yes there were three different ways
right so then when we
get over here why why do we have to
recompute the exact same thing
take a look at these two purple blocks i
just drew
notice how this decision tree looks the
exact same as this one
because in both cases we're solving the
exact
same sub problem and since we're doing
it depth first search
this one is going to be solved first
right so
if we solve this entire problem what we
said was
okay we found out starting at step two
there were three different ways to get
to step five so when we get here why
don't we just take
that result store it in memory store it
in dp
or basically this is a cache right we're
we're storing it in memory so then when
we get here we can just say we already
know the result of this
meaning that we don't need to draw out
the entire decision tree we're just
going to skip that all together we're
not going to draw this
we're not going to draw that and we're
not going to draw any
levels of this tree so as you can see
i'm eliminating
all that repeated work by saving that
solution
but that's not all right we see over
here
we're asking a different sub problem
starting at step three how many
different ways can we get to n equals
five
well in this case it was two different
ways right notice how this decision tree
is the exact same over here because
here we're asking that same question
starting at step three what's the number
of ways and since we're doing the step
for search
this one is going to end up being
computed before this one
so when we get here we can just say we
already know the answer is
2 so we don't need to run through the
entire decision tree again
so in this case as well we can eliminate
that repeated work so i'm just going to
cross this entire thing out
and we're not done yet see over here
we're asking starting at step four
how many ways can we get to five that
same problem is over here
notice how they have the exact same
decision tree this one is going to be
computed first because we're doing debt
for search
so once again let's eliminate this
repeated work
so now you can see when we do eliminate
all that repeated work
this is what our decision tree ends up
looking like and this
is roughly o of n this is
linear time solution reason being we're
only solving each sub problem once right
so we know that the first sub problem
the original problem is starting at zero
then we get a sub problem of
one two three four all the way to
five which is our base case right so
each of these sub problems is just being
solved once
n is five so overall the time complexity
is big o of n
and this is basically the the dynamic
programming solution where we are
caching the result aka memoization
so we're using memoization but this
problem can actually be solved with a
true dynamic programming solution
as you can see starting at the result
the the result
of zero depends on the sub problem
this one right and this sub problem
depends on another sub problem
which depends on another sub problem
which depends on our base case so why
don't we
start at the bottom solve the base case
and then work our way up to the original
problem
at zero right why don't we start at the
bottom work our way
up this is called a bottom up this is
called a bottom
up dynamic programming approach so
that's what i'm going to show you we're
going to start at the base case
and then work our way up so remember
we're starting
at position zero and our goal is to get
to the fifth step
right each time we can take one step or
we can take two steps right
so i'm going to be storing our result in
an array called dp
so we're going to have a position in dp
all the way from index
0 all the way up to index n which is
going to be our input value remember
so remember we're we're at the base case
initially right what's the base case
gonna be
well at the last step if we start here
how many different ways can we land here
well that's just gonna be
one right that's our default value so
now
that we solved that we are able to solve
this one right because remember this
problem depends on the sub problem of
this
so from here let's say we're starting
here we can take
one step which lands us at the result we
can take
two steps which lands us out of bounds
right so how many different ways
from here can we reach the goal again
it's going to be one
and do you notice how this is always
going to be the case
even if we had something like n equals a
hundred so let's say this was actually a
hundred and this was 99
this would always be one right this is
always gonna be one because
it's at the goal and starting from here
it's also always going to be
one because we can take one step which
would get us to the result or we could
take two steps which would get us out of
bounds so no matter what the n
e the input value n is this is always
going to be the case
it's always going to be uh 1 1.
next we're going to get to the
interesting part so then we want to know
okay how many different ways from here
can we reach
five well this depends on two sub
problems which come
after it right so we can take one step
over here or two steps over here right
so and then we get to the sub problem
right
so from four we don't need to continue
to figure out how many different ways
from four can we get to five because we
just computed that that's why we're
using dynamic programming that's why we
have this array because we already
computed
starting at four how many different ways
can we reach five and we also
starting at five how many different ways
can we reach five that's also
one so what we're gonna do in this value
is basically take
these next two values add them together
one plus one and then we're gonna get
two over here and we're gonna do the
exact same thing
for this position two so we know here we
could take one step
or two steps right so what we wanna do
from here three is find out how many
different ways can we reach five
we just computed that that's two and
from 4 we want to know how many
different ways can we reach
5 we also already computed that that's
one so what we can do is take
these two values add them together and
that's going to be
what we put here so starting at 2 we can
get to 5
three different ways and at this point i
bet you probably get the idea we're
gonna do the exact same thing over here
so what value are we gonna put over here
just take these
next two values add them together three
plus two is gonna be
five and remember this is what we were
originally trying to compute this is
going to be the result it depends on
only two sub problems
which are listed right after it five
plus three that's going to be eight so
that's the result
if you're familiar with what the
fibonacci sequence is the fibonacci
numbers
that's exactly what we're doing right
now we're starting at the base case of 1
adding these two values to get the next
result then we're adding these two
values to get three
then we're adding these two values to
get five then we're adding these two
values to get a
so you may or may not be familiar with
it but that's what we're doing
and you may have also noticed we're
using extra memory right we're having an
entire array size equals n that's going
to be o of n
extra memory but is it actually needed
to have an entire array
notice how each value such as this one
only depends on the two values that come
after it and this one only depended on
the two values that came
after it so in reality we don't need to
have an entire array we just need to
have
two different variables let's initialize
the two variables like this
one is gonna be this position two
is gonna be this position because
starting from here we wanna know how
many different ways could we reach the
result if we took
one step that's why this is called one
and if we took two steps
that's why this is called two and we're
basically going to be computing this
next value right and once we compute
this next value we're gonna shift our
one variable over here
and we're gonna shift our two variable
over here and we're going to keep doing
that until we get to the result
of zero and if we initialize two
initial variables one and two as values
one how many different
values do we have to compute that come
after in this case you can see we have
to compute
four values right so basically we
compute
n minus one values we have to loop n
minus one times and then when our one
variable
ends up getting in this position that's
what we're going to return
as the result so this was a really long
explanation because we did a lot of
analysis but when i actually show you
the code it's going to be really simple
using this idea of two variables being
shifted
n minus 1 times so as i said from the
drawing explanation we're gonna have two
variables one and two
both are going to be initialized as one
and
then we're just gonna loop through n
minus one time so for i in range
n minus one and we're gonna continuously
update these two variables one and two
so the first thing i'm gonna do is
update one
one is gonna be set to one plus two
right because we're just adding the two
previous values
and then getting the new result so one
is being updated and we would also want
to shift
two to whatever the previous value of
one
was but you can see that we're updating
one before we actually shift two so what
we're actually going to do is store
one in a temporary variable before
we actually update it and then we're
going to set two to the temporary
variable
so that we don't end up setting it to
one plus two we do we just want it to be
set to one so we're gonna set two equal
to temp
once this loop goes through n minus 1
times
we're going to end up just returning
whatever one happens to land on
and that is the entire solution we went
through so much headache just to get to
these five lines of code
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching